فترات الرخاء صارت عقوبه
بعد ما يعني ظلت سنوات هي سنوات حتى تماما
بحيث مثلا يعني انه حصه الواحد على الفطور
ربع رغيف مع ست حبات زيتون المفروض
البيضه تقسم على اربعه بالخيط بيقسموها
كل اربع اشخاص بيطلع لهم بيضه واحده يعني
ايوه يعني
[موسيقى]
حسب العدد بيطلع مثلا 100 واحد فيهم 25
بعض المسيونيين او المعتقلين ان يضعوا
اياديهم في الشوربه المغليه
هاي حاسه تكررت طبعا تكررت كثير يعني
ونفس المهاجع اللي كان بعض
السجانه الساديين يعني بيتبول
[موسيقى]
فوتوا بعيسى يعني سنوات الجوع
وسنه الشبع سنه استمرت هاي الحاله بمعنى
انه حاجه المهجع لنفرض متر رغيف بجيبوا
لهم 400 رغيف يعني في هدف معين هدف ممنوع
الكميات الزائده من الطعام من الخبز وين
بدهم يروحوا فيها خلقت مشاكل الى اول ما
لاخر يعني كيف بدنا نتخلص
هو خبز السمون العسكري
بدك تتخلص من 300 رغيف كل يوم زياده فبده
تمرسه بالماء
وممنوع تطلعوا طبعا ايوه تمرسه بالمي تسوي
سائل وترمي بالمرحاض طبعا
الصعيد الديني طبعا يعني
القدسيه اللي
بيعملوها المتدينين تجاه الخبز انه نعمه
الله حرام
في البدايات خلقت مشاكل كذا بالاخير
الواقع كان اقوى من يعني
لانه يعطوا الفتوى بانه
في مهمه بحيث انه يتعين مثلا عشر اشخاص
بالمهجع مهمتهم هو مرسى الخبز وكبه البنت